in the long history of the world the
planet has played host to a wide variety
of ancient civilizations there are far
far too many of those for any one video
to cover people make it their careers to
discover and catalog the civilizations
that preceded us in the modern era
archaeologists and historians make it
their life's work to learn everything
there is to know about these mighty
empires and kingdoms that span vast
swaths of land where there are now
dozens of countries a lot of these
civilizations are famous even school
children know about them take a look at
the roman empire for example everyone
knows about the mighty roman empire
julius caesar took control of the roman
republic and created the empire that
would go on to be one of the largest
empires in history at the time it
controlled practically everything in
europe and north africa and even parts
of asia the romans made amazing
advancements in culture architecture law
and practically everything else in fact
their legacy can even be seen in pop
culture today the american senate is
modeled off the roman senate and
practically every nation in the world
has their own kind of wine a roman
invention or take the macedonian empire
a lot of people don't know its name but
you almost definitely know the person
who created it alexander the great at
only 20 he took his father's throne then
he began launching military expeditions
and it soon became clear that young
alexander was a brilliant tactician
never defeated in battle he managed to
extend his vast empire across all of
west asia and north africa stretching
all the way to egypt and india like
caesar would go on to do after him he
managed to create one of the largest
empires in history except he did it all
before he even turned 30. though he died
young and his empire was split apart by
his generals he brought greek thought
culture and philosophy not to mention
science to the far reaches of inner asia
and of course there is the mongol empire
led by the fearsome genghis khan the
mongols and nomadic people from central
asia were divided into dozens of
distinct tribes until genghis khan
united them under one flag and from
there they spread outward violently into
the rest of asia conquering china korea
eastern europe and practically all of
asia in doing so they created the
largest empire in history and killed
somewhere near 40 million people in
their conquests 10 percent of the
world's population at the time but they
also created a safe trade route from
china to europe what is now known as the
silk road and their innovations with
cavalry would go on to inform warfare
using horses for the next 800 years
moving out of asia there are also the
legendary mayans the mayans were more of
a loose confederation of different
tribes working together to advance a
common civilization
they didn't conquer as much land as the
others only one area in central america
but they crafted a complex society with
laws civic duties social rules and
extremely advanced religious rights and
architecture if you go to south america
today you can still see the remnants of
their empire step pyramids that look
sort of like ziggurats deep in the south
american jungle interior they invented
astronomy calendars writing and many
forms of art like mosaics all without
contact with european society needless
to say the advancements empires have
made throughout history are so important
we use them in our daily lives all the
time and we know a lot about these
ancient empires too how could we not
they've made massive impacts on the
planet and population not to mention
religion culture law society as a whole
but what if there was an empire on the
planet that was larger and more advanced
than all the ones we just looked through
and not just more advanced by a little
bit so advanced that they were creating
nuclear reactors well before alexander
was taking his first steps or plutarch
was trying to complete a history of the
greeks so advanced that we still don't
totally understand what they were
capable of i'd certainly call that
anomalous wouldn't you and that's not
all what if this empire also managed to
stay hidden from modern science for
centuries they didn't stay alive but
their ruins have never been found by the
scientific community their relics have
been squirreled away from the eyes of
the world over the decades you'd never
find a reference to the mechanite empire
in a history textbook or in a museum and
that's for a very good reason the scp
foundation has spent an extremely large
amount of time and money ensuring that
the evidence of this ancient empire
never comes out to the rest of the world
but even if a culture creates anomalies
is the culture itself anomalous does it
need to be contained especially if
they're all long dead and their
technology has degraded into unusability
well
maybe except their technology is doing
just fine two thousand years and
counting their technology is still
working perfectly in some cases better
than our modern devices how can that be
possible how can that not be anomalous
well as unbelievable as it might seem
it's true we'll dive more into what
exactly this empire out of greece was in
a bit but for now we're going to look at
an scp file associated with them except
this one couldn't be picked up stuffed
in a box and shipped off to a
containment locker in site 19. you'll
see why in a minute but for now let's
just take a look at the file
scp-2406 lacks any images or flashy
documentation so no clues there unless
it's not possible to photograph the
anomaly for some reason
the object class is safe and the
containment procedures aren't very long
a site provisional site 31 has been
constructed around
scp-2406 and is under the cover of a
kazakhstani military base provisional
sites are temporary sites that the
foundation puts up in the field to
contain an anomaly that can easily be
transported somewhere else for
containment and if it's a kazakhstani
military facility the anomaly is
probably somewhere in kazakhstan and
can't be moved
seems reasonable enough all personnel
who work directly with
scp-2406 are required to wear a type a
hazmat suit when in contact with the
anomaly and to undergo a full
decontamination bath upon exiting
whatever
scp-2406 is being in direct contact with
it can be dangerous to humans so the
foundation uses specialized hazardous
material suits the big yellow jumpsuits
you see near radiation or chemical spill
sites on top of that an armed contingent
of guards are to remain in place in and
around provisional site 31 to ensure no
one unauthorized accesses the anomaly
though you'd have to wonder why anyone
would try to access a military base the
containment procedures close out by
declaring that anyone wanting to
directly interact with scp-2406-1
whatever it is needs to get
authorization from their site director
so
scp-2406 has at least one sub-anomaly to
deal with obviously the foundation is
very interested in keeping this anomaly
or these anomalies secret and protected
at all costs as well as limiting human
exposure to something potentially
dangerous now let's take a look at the
description
scp-2406 is a mechanical automaton
that's 93 meters tall and weighs
approximately 210 metric tons for the
americans among us that's about 300 feet
in height and 230 tons over 450 000
pounds no wonder the foundation couldn't
move it after investigating research
concluded that
scp-2406 wasn't sentient so it wasn't a
robot or cyborg or artificial
intelligence an automaton is a machine
to perform a specific task and this
thing whatever it is was controlled by
at least six different operators if not
more they piloted the machine using 160
different valves and levers within the
torso head and chest of the automaton
and if it has a head and chest it has
limbs limbs that were controlled by a
combination of pneumatics hydraulics and
clockwork machinery but controlling is
one thing how the heck does something
like this get the power to move the
answer is a nuclear reactor embedded in
its torso with power cables running to
its arms and legs yep unbelievable as it
may seem this ancient curiosity was
powered by the same source our modern
aircraft carriers and nuclear submarines
use
scp-2406 was discovered on august 7 1985
in the arlcom desert but not by the
foundation the arakum desert used to be
part of the rlc before the soviets
drained part of it it was during one of
these drainings that the russian
military discovered scp-2406
by tracking the radiation coming from it
as soon as they realized what they found
wasn't some sort of abandoned warhead or
uranium deposit they called in the gru's
p division the unit of the soviet
government who dealt with anomalies in
the same way the foundation did they
kept custody of the anomaly but only for
a few years when the ussr collapsed in
1991 the foundation stepped in with
their agents and took control of the
anomaly while everyone else in the area
was busy dealing with the political
fallout they immediately began
performing research and learned that the
material
scp-2406 is made of isn't just one metal
but a toughened alloy of copper zinc
nickel lead and iron the mixture is why
the metal looks bronze despite not
having any bronze in it they also found
two markings on it one was on the
outside of its back and showed the
aegean numeral for nine does that mean
there are at least eight more of these
things buried somewhere maybe but the
foundation hasn't found any of them
what's more interesting is that the
numeral is aegean greek despite
scp-2406 lying in a lake in the rlc
pretty far from greece the front of the
anomaly its chest has an intricate
symbol of a hammer striking an anvil on
it the right arm of the anomaly has a
nozzle with piping attached to it the
piping leads to a pressurized chamber
within scp-2406
that is empty but the foundation did
manage to find trace residue of various
chemicals such as pine resin naphtha
quicklime calcium phosphide and sulfur
inside the corners of the tank not
coincidentally those are the exact same
chemicals used to create greek fire a
primitive chemical weapon similar to
napalm that the ancient greeks used in
warfare between this and the aegean
numeral the foundation judged that
scp-2406 was almost definitely
constructed in greece and brought here
for some reason the left arm of the
anomaly isn't attached to it in fact
initial reports said it was torn off at
the shoulder and couldn't be found with
the rest of it but it seems that the
foundation managed to recover its sense
detailed in one of the addenda in the
file chemicals weren't the only thing
they found inside
scp-2406 when they busted the main
access plate open researchers found
something decidedly more morbid six
different human skeletons located inside
its torso area were removed and
cataloged before being carbon dated to
1100 bc
over 3 000 years old and they were all
wearing an extremely strange set of
armor while it looked greek it was made
of a strange lead copper alloy and
filled with asbestos lining presumably
the armor was designed to absorb the
radiation put out by
scp-2406's reactor there were also tubes
from the helmets leading to the outside
so they could breathe safe air one of
the levers pumped water into the tubes
so that the pilots didn't die of thirst
and another tube was near the groin
probably so they could pee seems like
the designers ensuring that whoever was
piloting
scp-2406 could do so for hours or days
the foundation ensured through testing
that scp-2406
doesn't work the limbs don't move and
many of the levers have rusted or broken
all of that damage from disuse is
repairable but there is even more
extensive damage from combat the limbs
and head were first discovered run
through by long sharp spikes made of an
unknown substance though it feels like
chitin its molecular structure is closer
to coral and on top of that it's
biological and contains some elements of
human dna parts of its limbs are also
crushed or indented with a segmented
pattern like a boa constrictor wrapping
around its prey the evidence suggests
that
scp-2406 was in an intense fight with
some sort of giant monster and lost but
that's all in the past
scp-2406 also has a more present problem
its reactor it melted through the back
of the anomaly penetrating the earth and
seems to still be burning incredibly hot
and radioactive nearly a kilometer under
the surface
engineers think that when it was intact
it works similarly to natural nuclear
reactions rather than modern reactors
like when a uranium deposit begins to
undergo fission if nothing else it means
that scp-2406
designers were studying those and were
far more advanced scientifically than
any other culture on the face of the
planet at the time that we know of while
they were investigating the wreck
foundation personnel also discovered
something interesting a watertight
ceramic jar like the ones ancient
egyptians used to preserve organs when
they broke the seal they found two
tightly bound scrolls written in a
unique language resembling mycenean
greek it took 10 years of research for
the foundation's best linguists to
translate the scrolls what they found
confirmed their theory the scrolls were
religious and written by a group called
the followers of meccan the ancient
precursors to what we now call the
infamous church of the broken god an
anomalous cult that seeks to rebuild
their deity and make themselves more
than human the foundations had run-ins
with them in the past but the documents
indicate that 3 000 years ago they
weren't just a cult they were an empire
the first scroll was translated to the
following the colossi were constructed
in her schema the colossi were
constructed to defend secure contain the
enemy grand karcist ion betrayer of man
destroyer of progress sorcerer king of
aritum a desolate domain a failed and
fallen creation built with the body's
flesh of dead gods upon a throne of
black ambition the enemy plots the enemy
is not a priest they are a merchant and
they have sold the whole world totality
the colossi were constructed in her
schema the colossi were constructed to
defend secure contain the profane tools
must be broken uncreated drink deep the
silver blood of meccan may her sacrifice
not be in vain strange but definitely
religious it seems to be a dedication to
the broken god mechane the colossi were
created to fight their ancient enemy the
sarcists but the second document is much
more interesting this is a testament of
matriarch uprexia legate's faithful
servant of meccan i am not a warrior but
all warriors are dead breaking
themselves upon the enemy's host the
enemy has set their plan into motion the
sorcerer king surrounds himself with
corpses to fight is to grow his legions
egypt retreats from the world the
hidites have fallen into chaos the
conspirators of crete have sacrificed
their own the asian have fallen into
barbarism the city of a thousand pillars
is forever lost has always been lost
even the deva grow desperate with the
enemy at their border the center
collapses kingdoms crumble the damage is
done the light of reason flickers and
wanes but mccain sacrificed herself so
that we might be free we refuse to
return to that darkness we would rather
die but the siege at euros was won we
must strike while the metal is hot and
thus we march for kythera at the end of
all things we have crossed the wine dark
sea we have seen villagers ravage by the
red death we have seen the dead the
dying and the deathless we cast the
accursed to holy flame we enter his
desolate domain and in our left hand we
carry our answer we cannot undo what has
been done but we can delay the circuit
done so it seems that the ancient
mechanite empire were once at war with
another empire the hated sarcists losing
and all their allies dying they poured
their resources into these massive mechs
and sent them deep into enemy territory
equipped with some sort of doomsday
weapon as a hope for success what
happens next is unfortunately a mystery
on december 12th of 1998 the foundation
found something almost 30 kilometers
away from
scp-2406 during a routine patrol at
first the researchers were confused had
they found another wreck one of the
other eight mentioned or perhaps the
body of the mysterious creature as cp
2406 had fallen in battle with but after
excavating it they realized they had
found something they hadn't even been
looking for to begin with
scp-2406's left arm the way it landed
suggested that it had been torn off
during the battle and hurled away but
what monster could possibly throw
something that heavy 30 entire
kilometers either way what the
foundation found attached to
scp-2406's arm is much more interesting
the researchers aren't sure what it is
but it's much different from the rest of
scp-2406
it seems to be some kind of weapon but
one that's not made of any metals on
earth and with an incredibly anomalous
design the foundation personnel not sure
of what to make of it designated it
scp-2406-1
its purpose is similarly unknown and the
consensus seems to be that whatever it
is it far exceeds human understanding
but what the foundation is sure of is
that it seems to bend reality near it
though they're not sure how because it
doesn't seem to affect anything the
foundation's best minds are stumped by
it all they can say for certain is that
if it was ever repaired powered up and
activated it could do unprecedented
damage to local reality so interaction
with it was highly regulated and the
foundation put it away with the rest of
scp-2406 now go check out
scp-2217 hammer and anvil and scp-001
the broken god or boro cycle for more
anomalous mechanite madness from scp
explained